[engine running]
[music playing]
So there's a part
of the Green Hell
that we call the Roller Coaster.
You come out of that
last high bank dirt turn
and enter into
the Fishbowl here.
This is the first of a series
of man-made log features here.
Yeah, this thing
is super steep, Glen.
You gotta carry speed
through this thing
or you're sliding
down into that junk.
Yeah, I mean we're getting--
you know, we're 40, 45
degrees here on this thing.
[engine roaring]
You want to stay high
and keep those tires dry,
because if you end
up down in that muck,
you're not going to
like the wobble boards.
[engine roaring]
He looks like he's hung up
on those wobble boards, guy.
Uh-oh.
You want to keep
your tires dry as you
come out of that last one.
Because this is what we
call the wobble boards.
And they do wobble, every one
of them that you drive over.
[laughter]
Dry tires will
certainly help out.
Yeah, this looks
like a lot of fun.
But it's absolutely no fun
with mud on your tires.
You end up on either side,
you're going on your lid.
[engine roaring]
[splash]
You want to keep the
middle of the wobble boards
right in the center
your vehicle.
You go too slow, the wobble
boards might hang you up.
You go too fast, you bounce
off and go off the side.
[engine revving]
[crash]
[laughter]
Once you get off of the wobble
boards, you gain composure.
And then you gotta carry
a little bit of speed
up the log hill here.
Because if you go
too slow, you end up
high siding on the top of it.
[engine roaring]
You want to carry enough
speed to not high side,
but not too much,
because it really
drops off on this back side.
You don't want to be carrying
any speed into the pond.
If you hit that thing, your
motor is going to flood,
you're out of it.
Well, there you go.
That's the Green
Hell Roller Coaster.
Kicked it up a notch for season
2-- bigger, stronger, faster.
[music playing]
What's happening, everybody?
We're here at the Kaolin
Climb, the last challenge
you have to make it
over before you can say
you defeated the Green Hell.
[engine running]
There he is!
Go, [inaudible], go!
Hammer it down.
Go, go, go, go!
We stepped everything
up here for season 2,
including the Kaolin Climb.
It was only at about
42% grade last season.
This season, it's
hovering right around 55%.
Right now, my
calves are burning.
Damn, that is steep.
And we're only
halfway up right now.
Once you make it up that
steep grade and it's dry,
you hit all of this,
this thick muck.
If you don't have the right
tire, it clogs the tire.
And you get about halfway up.
And you just slide
right back down.
[engine running]
He's gonna have to kick it up.
He's gotta rev it.
Let's go!
This course is both
natural and man-made.
We have dozers,
backhoes, excavators
out here working around the
clock to get the courses ready.
Right now, we've got our
boys up top finishing
watering down the Kaolin Climb.
We dumped thousands of gallons
of water down this last part.
But there's no way
to get a run at it.
Because where we're standing,
it's going to be deep.
Yeah, I've played in
a lot of mud before.
But this right here
is some nasty stuff.
[engine roaring]
MAN: He's at the top!
If you can make it this far,
if you can crest that hill,
well, you've made
it to holy ground.
You've conquered the Green Hell.
[engine roaring]
Yeah!
Woo!
[echoing]
This portion of the Green Hell
we call The Pond, with Halfway
Island in the middle.
You can go to the right or left.
It doesn't matter.
[engine roaring]
If you hit it with some speed,
your day might end right here.
The whole pond is
lined with kaolin,
and we've already told
you how slippery kaolin
is when it's wet.
The pond itself?
Well, I think it's
about knee deep.
[laughs]
This is a great opportunity for
a driver to throw it all away.
Get the motor wet here,
and your day is done.
[motor sputtering]
MAN: Well, that
certainly killed it.
GLEN PLAKE: It's important to
have good water preparation.
If you do have some
splash on the engine,
you want to make sure all
the electronics and the motor
is relatively protected.
MAN: It's full of water.
And the big thing
is the air intake.
Whether you got a snorkel,
or some sort of a deflection
scoop, really important not to
put any water into your engine
here.
MAN: Check up for the water.
ABE WINE: There he goes.
Smooth entry.
Oh, you're never
going to flood
your motor going that slow.
Hey, hey.
GLEN PLAKE: The thing is here
is it really tests the driver's
ability to slow
it down, not come
in here with a whole bunch of
speed, big old wave of water,
and get the engine wet.
He's out!
He's headed to you guys!
Yeah!
The pond can be
real tough on drivers.
But on a hot day in Georgia,
standing here knee-deep,
it's pretty nice for me.
[laughs]